hello everybody welcome to another tango
technique class at home i hope you are
all doing fine
today's class will be for men and women
the same and we will use our shoes but
if you're a woman i would recommend you
to the class without tangle shoes
without high heels because today's
exercises are quite heavy on balance and
they can be a bit
challenging and dangerous to do with
high heels so do them barefoot
or with flat shoes at least initially
until your body gets used to the
movements and your and gets also
stronger and then you can try with high
heels okay but at your own risk
and you will need a stick like this this
is from a mop that i just took the hell
out
and we will also use the metronome today
because we need a steady reference for
our timing yeah
so
today's exercises will help you with
your balance with the strength of your
standing leg
they will help you also develop strength
and control on your free leg because we
will move it very slowly using the
resistance of the own weight of the leg
we will use the knee as well
the exercises will also help improve
your core yeah your center because the
core is what holds everything that is
moving together
and because we have the stick
the exercises will also improve your
posture a lot because we will do all the
exercises while holding the stick above
our heads
and there are some tips about that as
well yeah so after the warm up with the
extra stretch for our calf muscles we
will do three exercises three long
exercises in which we will project our
free leg in different directions front
back and
side and we will also flex our standing
leg and we will hold the stick up of our
heads for posture yeah
so
if you practice these exercises
the benefit for your dance will be that
you will look
very straight
your dance will look very grounded on
the floor
and all your steps will look very
dynamic
very strong very secure and very
controlled
and also the exercises can help you with
gun shows
and with adornments as well yeah the
exercises will give you a lot of control
of your free layer okay
so i hope you enjoy the class let's go
for the warm-up okay warm up
so start with your feet together
make sure that the feet are parallel and
touching each other that your posture is
straight relax the shoulders
keep your head up looking forward and we
start with shoulder rotations yeah
remember not to use your elbows just
relax them and make big
slow rotations backwards with the
shoulders okay with the weight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight now we do rotations with the
arms so remember keep your elbows
straight all the time
and when you open the arms to the side
pass your hands behind your back so that
you stretch the chest muscles okay
and we do eight
one
slow
two
three
nice and slow
four
five
as wide as you can
six
seven
and
eight
okay
now we stretch the side of our torso so
we lift one arm we make sure that the
elbow is straight and then we slide with
the other hand down our leg until we can
touch the side of our knee and then we
hold this stretch
for three seconds and then we use the
hand that is on top to pull ourselves
back up and then we lower the arm and we
repeat to the other side okay
we do it four times with each side
okay let's go one
go down
hold it
and up
one
two down
for the stretch
and
up
two
go down
hold it
and up
and do
go down
hold it
and
three
go down
hold it
and up
and three
go down hold it
and up and the last one
four
go down hold it
and
up and four
go down
hold it
and
up
okay now we open the legs
a bit wider than your shoulders
we bend the knees slightly we keep the
hip straight
and also the head straight yeah
and we make a circle with our arms
make sure that your hands are below your
chest and then we rotate the torso left
and right yeah making sure that we are
not rotating the hip and that we keep
our hands in front of our chest all the
time
so that we work with the torso and not
with the arms yeah the torsion happens
here
below the ribcage okay and we do it
eight times twice okay let's go
ah
one
two three
four
five
six
seven
eight eight more one
two
three four
five
six
seven
and eight
okay now we stretch the knees we grab
our hips
we bend forward
from the hip yeah keeping our back
straight
until the back is parallel with the
floor and then we keep going down
using
the weight of our head we bend
and then when we are down we bounce
three times
bounce bounce bounce this will stretch
the back of your leg
and then we go up slowly
and this is one repetition yeah and with
the weight okay let's go
one go down
bounce bounce bounce
and walk
two
down
bounce bars bounce
four
three
down
bounce bounce bounce
go up
four
bounce bounce bounce
go up
five
go down
bounce bounce bounce
go up
six go down
bounce bounce bounce
go up
seven
down
bounce bounce bounce
go up and the last one eight
go down
bounce bounce bounce
and go up okay
now we keep the hands here on our hips
we go back with our hips slightly and
then we move our hip to the side yeah
keeping our legs straight
and then front and then to the other
side
and then back and we make a full wide
circle okay we do it eight times in one
direction and then we change eight times
on the other direction okay
so let's go we go back with the hip and
then
one
two
three make it as wide as you can
four
five
six
seven
and eight keep your torso straight all
the time yeah
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight
okay
now we join our legs
make sure that your feet are
parallel and touching each other okay
you can keep your hands on your hips if
you want
and now we strengthen our ankle joint so
we bend our knees we bounce three times
one two three then we stretch our knees
we go up on the toes and we hold this
position
for three seconds yeah keep your core
tight and keep looking forward yeah
and then we go down this is one
repetition we do eight okay let's go one
bounce bounce bounce
go up
hold it
and go down
two
bounce bounce bounce
go up keep your feet together hold it
and go down
three
bounce bounce bounce
go up
hold it
and go down
four
palms palms bounce
go up
hold it keep your core tight
and go down slowly five
bounce pass bounce
go up
hold it
go down
six
bounce bounce bounce
go up
hold it
and go down seven
bounce bounce bounce
go up
hold it
go down
eight
bounce bounce bounce
go up hold it
and go down slowly okay
and now the last one
show you from profile
we stretch our calf muscles and achilles
tendon so you start with feet together
straight posture
and then you move one leg doesn't matter
which one
behind
the length of a long step yeah make sure
that your foot is right behind you yeah
below the center of your of your back
and not open to the side yeah
put it really behind
and then make sure that the heel is on
the floor the whole time and that the
leg is straight yeah
then bend the knee forward the front
knee bent forward until you feel the
calf muscle stretching and then hold
this position for 25 seconds let's count
one
10. 1
[Music]
nine
ten
one
two
three
four
five and then get out of the stretch
slowly by stretching the front leg okay
good now let's do it to the other side
so we start with
feet together
straight posture
and then move the other foot
backwards
yeah
the length of a long step
put the heel on the floor make sure that
the leg is completely straight and then
bend the front knee forward
until you feel the calf muscle
really stretching really pulling and
let's come 25 seconds
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
one
two
three
four
five and then get out of the stretch
slowly by by straightening your front
knee okay
if holding the balance like this is a
bit difficult then
you can help yourself with the wall yeah
you can just put both hands
or at least the fingers on the wall and
then
step quite close to the wall so that you
can go away with the back leg yeah and
then you just do it like this this is
much easier and you can use this to
help you concentrate on the stretch yeah
but if you can then just do it without
the wall okay
great so that was the warm up let's go
to the first exercise okay the first
exercise will be very simple and you
need your stick and this exercise will
work on your balance
your core and your posture yeah
and the exercise works like this so
first
you put your feet together yeah
then you hold the stick in front of you
like this yeah quite wide from the edges
then you find your balance on top of one
leg yeah and you raise your free foot a
little bit to make sure you are really
on one leg okay
and then you raise the stick above your
head like this
and you wait in this position for 25
seconds that's the exercise yeah then we
lower the stick we change the other leg
and we wait 25 seconds on the other leg
okay now before we do it one tip about
the stick
how to raise it properly if you just put
the stick above your head like this the
exercise won't really help your posture
and also you will get tired your arms
will get tired and your shoulders will
start hurting so
the right way to lift the stick over
your head is
to raise your rib cage yeah just put
your ribcage forward and up yeah so when
you move the arms up
you do it from the ribcage
to do this you will need to engage your
back muscles especially the muscles on
the upper back around your
shoulder blades yeah
so when you have your ribcage up
and your back engaged you will feel that
the arms can relax quite a lot yeah you
can hold the stick for a long time
without getting tired because the arms
and the shoulders are being supported
by the ribcage and by your whole muscles
on the side and on the back yeah that's
the right way to do it
if you want you can also use some
visualization and imagine
that you are actually hanging from the
stick yeah that the stick is supported
on the ceiling
and you're just hanging from it
yeah that also helps a lot okay
so let's do it together
we'll repeat it
on one leg then the other leg and then
we will do it again on both legs so feet
together hold the stick in front of you
why
find your balance on one leg you can
mirror me
and then lift your free foot a little
bit then raise the stick above your head
by lifting the rib cage
engage your back and let's count 25
seconds
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
one
two
three
four
and five okay relax the arms relax the
legs
if your arms get tired at some point
during the exercise what you should do
when you feel that is to raise your rib
cage again yeah
don't try to do anything with the arms
if you feel that they get tired instead
raise the rib cage again yeah pull it up
and reengage your back muscles then you
will feel that the arms can immediately
relax yeah that's the right thing okay
let's do it with the other leg so
feet together find your balance on the
other leg
uh put your foot
up a little bit
and then put the stick above your head
by raising the rib cage
and let's count 25 seconds
2 three
four
[Music]
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
one
two
three
four
and five okay
what helps a lot also for balance is to
find something in front of you that you
can look at you have something on your
horizon just fix your eyes there
and hold it and this will help you to
keep your balance okay so let's repeat
the whole thing one more time
feet together find your balance on the
first leg
lift your free foot a little bit
raise the stick above your head
make sure your rib cage is up
and then let's count 25 seconds one
two
one
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
one
two
three
four
five okay relax the arms relax the legs
if you need to
and then let's do it to the other side
find your balance
lift your foot a little bit
raise the stick above your head make
sure your back is engaged and your
ribcage is up
look at
the front of you some point in the
horizon and let's count 25 seconds
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
one
two
three
four
five
okay relax
and that was the first exercise let's go
to the second one okay on the second
exercise
we will start working with our free leg
and we will use the weight of the leg
itself
in order to work yeah in this exercise
we will concentrate on projecting the
leg forward
and the exercise works like this i show
you from the profile because it's easier
to see it
so first you put your feet together make
sure your
poster is straight then you hold the
stick in front of you why like we did
before
and then you find your balance on top of
one leg whichever leg you prefer and you
keep the free foot without weight but
touching the floor
then you raise the stick above your head
by lifting the ribcage and engaging your
back muscles yeah
and then we have a sequence of four
movements yeah
the first movement is
you project the free leg forward
straight and at the same time you bend
the standing leg like this yeah the knee
on the second movement you bend the free
leg like this
so
until your foot touches the knee of the
standing leg
then on the third movement you
stretch the free leg again
and on the fourth movement you lower the
free leg and you straighten the knee of
the standing leg okay
so we have
one
two
three
four okay
now one tip about the three leg when you
project it forward
it doesn't matter how high it goes
the point of the exercise is not to lift
the leg high yeah
but instead to project it forward
so don't think up
think
forward yeah
if you only lift your foot
just like this very close to the floor
that's completely fine yeah
okay that's the area because the idea is
to use a projection that helps you for
steps
so in steps you don't need to raise the
leg okay
now for this exercise we will use
the metronome
yeah i have set it up at 58 ppm
that's the tempo
and
two bits per bar that's the time
signature
and why do we use the metronome for this
because we could just count we could
count on our own one two three four
um
there are two reasons first is because
as you do the exercise you might get
tired and then there is a strong
temptation to do each repetition a
little bit faster yeah just because you
want to get over with them
so
the metronome
with a steady tempo
forces you to do each repetition exactly
at the same speed
and you get much more from the exercise
yeah the second reason is that there are
some movements in this sequence that we
have
that you might finish too early for
example when you want to lower your free
leg yeah if your balance is not good you
are
not in control then you might lower it
too early yeah and the tempo of the
metronome
shows you exactly at what
moment in time should each movement
finish
if you follow the beat yeah
so those are the two reasons yeah just
that you make the exercise really honest
keeping the same tempo all the time and
that each movement happens at the right
tempo okay
good so
i will put the metronome here
and we will use
the down bits of the method for our
movements yeah so it will be
one
two
three
four yeah on the down lead and we will
do it eight times eight repetitions then
we will switch do it to the other side
with the other leg and then we will
repeat the whole exercise again one more
time okay
so let's do it together
put your feet together make sure your
posture is straight
then find your balance
on one leg
keep the free foot on the floor without
weight
then raise the stick above your head
make sure your rib cage is up
and your back muscles are engaged so
that your arms can relax yeah
and then let's go and do it eight times
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
eight
two
three
[Music]
four
okay
good relax the arms during the exercise
don't forget your ribcage yeah if you
concentrate on your legs a lot your
chest might start going down because you
forget about it so make sure that
you keep the ribcage up and then you
keep looking at a point in front of you
then this will help you with balance
okay let's move to the other side so
feet together
find your balance on the other leg
keep the free foot on the floor but
without weight
then raise the stick
make sure your rib cage is up
and let's do it eight times
ah
one
two
three
four
two
three
four three
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
two
three
four
okay
try to take your time for each movement
and don't rush it yeah do it exactly
with a beat
and to do it so slow it will give you a
lot of strength
a lot of control for your movements okay
so let's do it one more time
fit together
and find your balance on the first leg
then keep the foot down on the floor
put the stick above your head make sure
your rib crease is up
let's do it eight times
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
three two
three
four
four two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
eight
two
three
four
okay relax
the shoulders relax the legs
and let's do it one last time to each
side
okay so feet together
find your balance on the other leg
and make sure your standing foot is
completely flat on the floor the toes
are open
move them a little bit
then keep the free foot on the floor
put the stick above your head make sure
your rib cage is
really up and ready forward yeah and
your back
muscles are engaged and let's do it
eight times
ah
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four seven
two
three
four
eight
two
three
four
okay
great
that's it let's go to the next exercise
okay this exercise will be quite similar
to the previous one but instead of
projecting the free leg forward will
project the free leg to the side okay
and the exercise is like this i'll show
you from the front because it's much
easier to see
so you start with your feet together you
hold the stick wide in front of you and
then you find your balance on one leg
you can just mirror me okay
and then
you keep the three foot on the floor
then
you raise the stick above your head
making sure that you lift your rib cage
when you do so and that you engage the
muscles on your upper back then your
arms will be relaxed okay
and then we have four movements again
the first movement is
you open and project your three legs
straight to the side and at the same
time you bend the knee of the standing
leg yeah
the second movement is you bend the free
leg like this yeah as if you wanted to
hook something against you
close the leg as much as you can yeah
then the third movement you open
the free leg again you stretch the knee
and the fourth movement you lower
the free leg and you straighten
the standing leg okay
and then you repeat it
we have
one
two
three and four yeah
remember is not about lifting the free
leg a lot
it's more about projecting it
far to the side yeah because this
exercise is designed to strengthen the
muscles that you need for a side step
yeah for a very good side step
so you know that when you do a side step
it's not about lifting the leg it's
about projecting the leg and going to
the side okay so that's what you want to
do
and the second thing as i said before
while you're doing the exercise
don't forget your chest keep your rib
cage up all the time if you start
feeling tired in your arms then lift the
ribcage even more yeah
okay and we will do it with a metronome
again to keep a steady tempo for each
repetition and for each movement okay we
will do each movement exactly on the
beat
okay let's do it
eight times
with one leg so feet together
hold the stick in front of you find your
balance on one leg keep the free foot on
the floor
then raise the stick above your head
lifting the ribcage and engaging your
back and then let's do it eight times
together
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
4.
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
eight
two
three
and four okay
relax your arms relax your legs and
let's do it to the other side
so feet together
prepare yourself make sure your poster
is straight
find your balance on the other leg
then raise the stick
rib cage up back engaged
unless we three times
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
eight
two
three four
okay
another thing is
when you lift
the free leg yeah you project it to the
side try not to tilt your torso in the
opposite direction yeah because
especially with the stick on top of your
head you will lose your balance yeah so
no matter what your feeling is doing
yeah keep your torso always straight
yeah here just go down okay
with a straighters okay let's do it
again
with both legs eight times yeah and this
time i will show you from behind
so that you
see now how the bearings are
okay
so
feet together
now find your balance on the first leg
that we practiced
then raise your stick above your head
make sure your chest is up your rib cage
is up and the back muscles are engaged
and let's do it eight times
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
8 two
three
four
okay
relax the arms relax the legs if you
need to
and then let's do it to the other side
feet together
stay posture
find your balance on the other leg
keep the three foot on the floor then
raise the stick and make sure your rib
cage is forward and up and your backing
edge
and let's do it
eight times to the other side
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two three
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
and eight
two
three
and four
okay relax
and let's go to the last exercise okay
in this last exercise we will project
our free leg back yeah and the exercise
works like this i will show you from
profile again because it's the best
angle
you start with your feet together
make sure your posture is straight you
hold the stick in front of you wide like
this yeah
and then you find your balance on one
leg yeah whichever leg you prefer and
you keep your free foot on the floor
touching the floor but without weight
then after you have your balance then
you raise the stick above your head
making sure that you lift the ribcage
and you engage the muscles on your upper
back yeah then your arms can relax
and then we have again four movements
yeah like before on the first movement
you project
the free leg back making sure that it's
straight and at the same time you bend
the knee of your standing legs you go
down on the second movement you bend the
knee of the free leg and you
close the leg as much as you can and you
want to really hook something like in a
gun
on the third movement
you straight
you make your free legs straight yeah
you stretch the knee
and on the fourth movement you close the
free leg and you straighten
the standing leg okay
now a few tips for this
is that when you're projecting the leg
back
try to avoid tilting your torso forward
yeah like this
because with the stick on top of your
head you will lose your balance yeah
so try to separate the movement on your
hip
so that no matter what you do with your
free leg
your torso stays unaffected okay
also when you bend the standing leg try
not to go forward like this yeah
because that's wrong that's not good for
your balance try to really have the
feeling
that you are going
down yeah directly down
there is a good tip for this which is um
when you project the leg back or when
you bend the standing leg if you feel
that your abdomen
starts descending yeah like it gets very
long and round forward
that's bad
that's why yeah if something like this
happens yeah it's also painful so no
matter what you do with your legs your
torso should not be unaffected so when
you project the leg and you bend the
standing leg yeah make sure that your
abdomen still feels
compact yeah
are not distended
yeah
this is a little bit hard in the
beginning but
you will get it yeah if you keep your
core tight you will get it okay
so we will do it eight times yeah with
the metronome so that we have a
perfectly regular
and precise movement
let's go to this style
eight times together
okay so
fit together find your balance
first then
stick over your head make sure your rib
cage is foreign and your back is engaged
and let's do it eight times together
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
eight
two
three
four
okay relax
i have a little bit of your losses i
always have it so my hip always has the
tendency to go back like this
this is my personal fight always to keep
my hips straight so maybe when you do
when you see me doing the exercise maybe
you see that the heat goes a bit back
but it shouldn't okay i'm doing my best
okay so let's do it to this side
make sure your poster is straight your
hip is straight
find your balance on the other leg
put your stick on top of your head
make sure your rib cage is up your back
is engaged
and then let's do it eight times
ah
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two three
four
seven
two
three
four
eight
two
three
four
okay relax
now
if this is too challenging with the
balance and the leg and everything
you can try initially
to each movement smaller for example
when you project the leg you just
project it like this very small when
you're bending standing leg you bend it
only like this that is enough when you
bend the knee you can not close
completely yeah
just to get a feeling for the exercise
when you get stronger and then you get
more confident
you can expand all these movements so
you can project more
you can bend more
you can flex more yeah
and so on so you expand the movements
you do the movements bigger as you get
more confident okay
so let's repeat the whole thing eight
more times with each leg
so feet together find your balance on
one leg
put the stick on top of your head
make sure your rib cage is up
your
your back feels engaged and wide
and then let's do it eight times
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three four
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
eight
two
three
and four
okay now let's do it one last time to
each side
relax your shoulders
and
feet together find your balance
then put the stick above your head
ribcage out back engage
and every day times
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
eight two
three
and four
okay and we are done
yeah
that was the last
exercise and
just a few final tips uh because you are
working with your free leg so slowly
lifting bending extending
uh in all
directions this will give you a lot of
control of your free leg and a lot of
strength so later when you want to do
these things fast
it will be very easy yeah you will be
able to do anything you want with your
free leg without affecting your balance
because the rest of your muscles the
core the chest the standing leg
will be very trained
so you can do things with your free leg
without affecting your balance at all
okay
now
if you want to add a little bit more
difficulty for example remember the
first exercise we did
which was just without using the free
leg
only practicing balance on one leg with
a stick above your head well if you want
to add a bit more difficult to this
exercise
what you can do is instead of standing
with your
standing foot completely on the floor
you can shift your weight a little bit
forward and raise the heel
yeah
i will show you from the back
so
this was the position for the first
exercise
now you go a little bit forward
and then you raise your heel
and you just stand there
for a while
yeah and then with your leg
put your weight a little bit forward on
top of the ball of your foot
and then
raise your heel this is more difficult
of course and stay there for
i know as long as you can
of course this will force a lot your
calf muscle it will be working a lot
and of course your core will work like
crazy as well so this is great for
balancing for posture yeah but if you do
this one don't forget to later do this
stretch yeah
to
relax the calf muscle and stretch it
together yeah with both legs okay so you
have to take care of your body
okay so i hope you enjoyed today's class
thank you for watching thank you also
for supporting the channel
and i will see you on the next video bye